so the national football league over the
course of the last 10 years chris has
been trying to take away the play that
has been described on the record
by members of the competition committee
like rich mckay as the most dangerous
play in the game
which you know if i was your lawyer i'd
probably not tell you to use those terms
if the goal is to avoid potential
liability you don't want to call it the
most dangerous play in the game but you
know what
it is the most dangerous play in the
game so they've been trying
to minimize it they've done it by moving
the kickoff point they've done it by
changing the touch back point they've
done it with
a bunch of tweaks and twists and
eventually
they did a massive reconfiguration of
the kickoff
structure which has the unintended
consequence chris
of making it harder to recover an onside
kick because you can't get a running
start anymore
so as it becomes harder and harder for
the team that is trailing
to mount a comeback and roger goodell
has said this before who does he root
for he roots for the team that's behind
he wants the games to be exciting they
have considered and according to goodell
yesterday when talking to reporters they
will consider
the fourth and 15 play as the
alternative
to the onside kick i like it
i think it's exciting i think it could
be a hell of a lot of fun i like the
fourth and 15 play as the replacement
for the kickoff frankly because
you just punt rather than kick off
if you want to give possession to the
other team and not try to keep
possession of the ball by converting on
fourth and 15.
i like it what do you think well i
listen i i like it
like to a degree all right there's some
things i don't like first off
i hate the premise all right just like
what you just said with like roger
goodell and all that that's the first
thing
hey sometimes you get your butt beat and
you don't deserve the kit to come back
in the game
sorry oh gosh everybody gets but there's
all
everybody gets always ribbons stop just
stop
stop you sound like people that you do
not have anything in common with when
you use that
i don't care that's what i feel about it
don't tell me how i feel mike shut up
but there's always been
no but let me finish my point i don't
care
it doesn't matter it's not well then
maybe you're one of them well i
am fine great put me in that list of the
category of people i don't know what the
hell you're talking about of all right
but with special teams are a part of
football
now you're favoring this is where i
don't like it you're favoring teams that
are
patrick mahomes that can throw the
football lamar jackson and the ravens
aren't favored there that sucks for them
better quarterbacks well i don't like
but or maybe they find so get a better
quarterback see that's a bull crap
comment mike stop i mean he's one of the
five best quarterbacks in football we
know that
now throwing the ball past 15 yards is
not his strength
so can they come up with a way to go
okay now it's
five yards and you run the football like
maybe maybe that like can you say
something like that but to me
now you're asking teams to reorganize
their
roster or their like it's just not i
don't think it's totally fair that way
where the other way yeah
it was about special teams in that third
phrase that phase
the problem the problem is it's become
dramatically harder
for a team to recover an onside kick yes
and and look
if the kickoff is so dangerous then
maybe you just do get rid of it all
together and replace it with fourth and
15. now i don't know how much safer the
punt
play is than the kickoff but at least
with you know the traditional kickoff
configuration that they've gotten away
from you don't have these two
large strong fast guys running at each
other
this is basic newtonian physics yeah and
they
crash and they dip their heads
instinctively and you have intense
pressure on the cervical spine and you
get a kevin everett situation or eric
legrand so
yeah we'll be talking about that for
sure i'm sorry i told you to shut up
right after this
that's all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports